la recette de thierry marx est désormais
connue et éprouvée plonger directement
dans le grand bain une dizaine d'élèves
éplucher en 12 semaines toutes les
facettes d'un métier complexe à la
sortie vous obtenez des commis de
cuisine prêt à l'emploi vous m'écoutez
vous me regardez j'ai pas entendu
merci beaucoup aujourd'hui la nouvelle
promotion s'initiaient à la brunoise de
légumes à la et on pousse avec une
brunoise comme je voulais dit ça fait
combien de mm on va à peu près 4 mm je
vais vous montrer comment on utilise le
couteau et comme on est mince tous les
cuisiniers vous le diront une fois qu'on
arrive à maîtriser la découpe le geste
la posture l'attitude le reste en
découle facilement ils ont entre 20 et
50 ans certains viennent du sud ouest
d'autres de la région lyonnaise
ce qui les intéresse c'est la rapidité
d'exécution à la clé l'équivalent d'un
c'est un pays sachant j'ai déjà fait des
études avancées repartir par exemple sur
un ca fait de deux ans c'est un peu long
surtout surtout qu'il ya vraiment
beaucoup de choses à faire on emploie
quoi normalement on doit poser vraiment
dès le départ un peu plus loin une autre
brigade apprend les bases du service en
salle pour tous la formation est
gratuite et l'emploi quasiment garanti à
la sortie la quatrième station est en
stage actuellement les trois premières
sessions c'est plutôt vraiment positif 1
c'est au delà de 70 % de retour à
l'emploi
quelle est la validité d'une telle
formation nous avons rencontré laurent
aujourd'hui en stage seul avec un chef
il s'accroche quand d'autres déchante
très rapidement la restauration c'est
voilà ça marche un petit peu ralenti
donc on n'est pas sûr non plus deux mais
c'est compliqué comme y arrivera dans la
plupart des restaurants avec avec un
soutien ça nous fait découvrir donc du
coup la vraie
la vraie vie la réalité et à nous après
de fer avec ou de fer semble aujourd'hui
en france on estime que près de 50000
emplois ne sont pas pourvus dans les
métiers de la restauration